Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision deleted scenes video from the finale
and there are a couple other big deleted scenes
from across the series that will break down so
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos falcon and winter
soldier episode 1 is going to be dropping next
week i'll be doing videos for all those episodes
too careful for spoilers from all the Wandavision
episodes so far if you haven't seen the series yet
but since the finale the producers the creators
and elizabeth olsen some of the other actors have
come out and explained what was going on with
the episodes there were a lot of hanging plot
threads a lot of open-ended story lines and things
that seemingly went nowhere like clues for big
payoffs that never came so they answered a lot of
questions about what was going on with that stuff
some of it was on purpose some of it was not on
purpose so if you felt like there were some things
that were missing especially from the finale
there are some big answers about that so one of
the biggest things that they had to get rid of in
the storyline was a big subplot with evan peters
ralph character monica rambeau the darkhold
senior scratchy in the twins and darcy's
character remember we only saw darcy for that one
really brief moment taking down tyler heyward in
the fidelity and then she never came back again
like they had a line of dialogue about her in
the mid credit scene with monica rambeau and
jimmy woo like oh she said the debriefs are lame
but they did actually have a much bigger scene
addressing what was going on with that character
there were a lot of reshoots that also happened
because of the virus i'll explain and actors
that weren't able to come back so there were some
things that they were not able to fix before they
actually dropped the episode i know there were a
lot of people that were upset by the payoff with
evan peters character expecting something bigger
with him why are you going to do quicksilver if
you weren't actually going to do quicksilver then
you have all these hints and teasers about senior
scratchy throughout the episodes it seems like
there's going to be some big payoff with his
character turns out that was part of the deleted
scenes because they couldn't finish the special
effects in time so what was going to happen is
that evan peter's character ralph bonner was
going to catch monica rambeau snooping on their
house snoopers going to snoop but while they
were there once monica rambeau freed him of agatha
harkness's influence he was actually going to turn
good and try to help them stop agatha the hardness
and take the darkhold so while scarlet witch nag
of the hardness are having their battle their
back and forth during the finale you have all
this separate stuff happening with ralph monica
rambeau darcy in the twins character trying to
steal the darkhold from agatha harkness's basement
or technically it was ralph's basement what was
going to happen though is that senior scratchy
was going to be guarding it for agatha harkness
so in the last couple of episodes that we saw him
you just see agatha the hardness stroking him like
oh clearly there's going to be some sort of reveal
like we found out that she was out of the harkness
but they haven't fully revealed what was
going on with the bunny this whole time
so while monica rambeau is busy freeing ralph you
have the twins moving in to help because billy
and tommy want to do something too they wind
up going to agatha harkness's house and then
as they go down into the basement down into her
lair that she had enchanted with all those runes
senior scratchy was going to turn into a giant
demon and literally try to scratch them like
that was what the name was all about like a funny
reference about him having giant claws a lot of
people heard this and they're like does that mean
that he was going to turn into mephisto or some
larger more important marvel comic book demon now
he was just going to turn into a general demon
that was being controlled by agatha harkness so
you have this big fight scene with monica rambeau
ralph in the background cowering in fear and
then the twins using their powers as well trying
to stop senior scratchy while they try to get
their hands on the darkhold now obviously agatha
harkness still winds up getting the dark hole
during the finale so eventually they would have
been unsuccessful but it would have been a much
bigger marvel movie style action scene where you
see monica rambeau using her powers in a bigger
way the twins using their powers in a bigger way
and you would have had a bigger payoff for the
ralph character because obviously we all wonder
what happens to ralph after the end of the series
like evan peters character just goes back to his
normal life because she enchants agatha harkness
back into that identity of the nosey neighbor
and presumably she's just going to move back into
his house darcy would have also been helping them
do this the whole time before she shows up
to take down tyler hayward because that was
going to be one of the last big things that she
does before she shows up at the end of the episode
but it's a whole bunch of scenes it would have
made the episode way longer if you're wondering
why the episode felt shorter than it was supposed
to be even though they were hyping it up as being
super long compared to the other episodes the main
reason why they got rid of all that stuff is just
they didn't have the time to finish the special
effects before they needed to air the finale
normally when they do stuff like that though when
they delete whole story lines it creates some
continuity errors and they fix it with scenes
that they add in reshoots like little moments
of dialogue to just address stuff originally they
would have brought darcy's character back in this
mid-credit scene with jimmy woo's character and
she would have just been present for that debrief
scene i believe the reason why kat dennings did
not come back to do that though is just because of
travel restrictions during the virus she just
wasn't able to travel to actually come back and
film the scenes the next big thing that they
actually got rid of was a full episode so matt
shakman the director of the series he directed all
the episodes said that originally they had planned
to do a full 10 episode run just because that's
a standard number for limited series like this
the reason why he said they got rid of it was
mostly for budget and for pacing issues because
the way they wanted to tell the story with the
sitcoms at the beginning then sort of spiraling
into the crazier stuff as you start to find out
what's actually going on and it turns into more
of a traditional marvel avengers movie but for
those of you that saw all the reports about a
secret 10th episode that's probably what was
being referenced they said that when they got
rid of that 10th episode a lot of those moments
just got put into other episodes so it's not like
there's an entire episode of deleted scenes or
anything like that the producer played it pretty
coy when she was trying to explain why benedict
cumberbatch's doctor strange character didn't
have a cameo scene if so much of this was building
up to a big doctor strange 2 crossover there were
a lot of things that they planned to do and a lot
of things that they never planned to do on purpose
it sounds like they weren't able to include him
just because of travel restrictions during the
virus the same reason why darcy couldn't
come back to film a scene for the end
i believe benedict cumberbatch was trapped in new
zealand just under travel restrictions while they
were busy filming all the stuff that would have
been in the finale for that post-credits scene
and for whatever reason they just decided not to
try and bend over backwards to do some sort of
green screen skype session to try and include
him they just decided to just forget about it
and let them address it when they get to doctor
strange 2 but hopefully that sort of clears that
up because it did seem like they were building
up to a big cameo scene and logically you would
expect him to show up at some point to address the
darkhold there are a lot of people that actually
doubt whether or not they ever plan to include
his character here's the thing about that the
producers were asked a lot of questions about
why they didn't include characters like mephisto
or big marvel cosmic villains they said that
there was never any plan to include a big bad
like that like mephisto was never part of their
plan so i think if benedict cumberbatch was never
supposed to have a cameo they would have said
the same thing oh he never was supposed to have
this he was never part of our plan but instead
their comment was more like well you know things
went down the way they went down like it sounds
like it just didn't work out like they wanted
to do it but it just didn't work out because of
scheduling but that also obviously answers the
mephisto question people wondering was there ever
supposed to be a big bad like nightmare mephisto
or cathone because they kept referencing the
darkhold chaos magic and he's the god of chaos
the way they talk about it their grand plan
for the series was to just tell the story about
scarlet witch dealing with her grief in agatha
harkness trying to take advantage of that in
that they didn't actually view agatha harkness as
the villain of the series the main writer actually
said that she wrote things so that scarlet
witch would come off feeling like more of a grey
anti-hero type of character like a winter soldier
type character someone who you normally think of
as a hero like she's an avengers character but
who has also killed a lot of innocent people
so if you felt like the moment she went out on
with monica rambeau didn't really address any of
the consequences of what she did like they'll
never know what you gave up this is that they
wrote it that way specifically so that she would
come off feeling like a very dark character and
that theme would continue during doctor strange
2 kevin feige did say that her character scarlet
witch is going to be crucial to what's going on
during the story in marvel phase 4 building up
into multiverse of madness so it's still a little
early to start theory crafting about the plot of
doctor strange 2 but i do think that we'll see
more of her going off the rails causing as many
problems as she helped solve like the prophecy the
darkhold says she's destined to destroy the world
also answering some of the questions about the
multiverse and evan peters character so elizabeth
olsen actually just made a recent comment that
she didn't truly understand how the marvel
multiverse worked or the mcu multiverse worked
until she started working on doctor strange 2
in that when they were talking about evan peters
coming on the show they never really had any
big multiverse conversations or they never really
explained it to her mostly the idea with including
him instead of aaron taylor johnson's version of
quicksilver was to show just how crazy she had
gone how far she was willing to go to bend over
backwards to make it seem like everything inside
the hex was totally normal and nothing was wrong
they did get into a little bit of multiverse stuff
explaining her as a nexus character but they
didn't completely explain that kind of leaving
it open-ended for them to deal with during doctor
strange 2 as with white vision just sort of flying
off into the distance and then not answering
what happens with him next they said they did a
lot of that stuff on purpose just sort of viewing
Wandavision as a series is like the next episode
in a series of episodes of the story of the mcu
in the next big episode of that like episode 10 of
Wandavision really is doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness normally when you have a limited series
that's only going to run for one season they
answer pretty much all the questions in the finale
but they never plan to do that with Wandavision
and kevin feige actually recently came out and
clarified some of his statements about Wandavision
season 2. he said that when they initially did the
series they didn't do it with the intention that
they would set up a season two so if they ever
do come back to season two it'll be a completely
fresh story just building on whatever they've just
done with her character in doctor strange 2 so
there is a chance that they could do season two
and they have a couple moments in the finale
where they address it like family is forever
and then vision tells her if we've said goodbye
so many times then i have to surmise that we'll
say hello again eventually but i think the whole
idea with vision's character is that white vision
will eventually become the regular version of
vision again once he is able to process all of his
original memories but paul bettany said that he
would play the vision character forever he'll keep
coming back as many times as marvel wants him back
so of course we will see white vision come back in
a future story somewhere more about quicksilver
though they said early on they did actually think
about doing aaron taylor johnson's quicksilver
but because they were doing this whole story with
scarlet witch going off the rails they felt like
the evan peters twist played into that much better
for those of you wondering about monica rambeau 's
engineer that had been hyped up during episode 5
tayonna paris the actress who plays monica rambeau
was saying it was going to be this big payoff then
it wound up being this character major goodner
that really didn't seem like anybody special
the director matt shakman said that was just
over hyped it was never meant to be a really
special character it was never meant to be a
fantastic four person it was never meant to
be the blue marvel although it does sound like
based on a casting notice for captain marvel 2
that they're planning on doing blue marvel during
that movie there was a big scene during episode
8 where you see the flashback where she goes to
visit vision's body at the sword headquarters and
tyler hayward is trying to gaslight her so that
she'll juice up his body with a bunch of her chaos
magic and activate him there was an alternate
version of this scene with a bunch of different
dialogue where she starts referencing avengers
end game in all the other avengers that died
she references black widow dying she references
iron man dying a bunch of the other big characters
like captain america but it was all in service of
saying why aren't we paying attention to what's
happening with vision like nobody cares about him
everyone just kind of left him on the battlefield
there i think they changed that to her simpler
dialogue about wanting to bury vision's body
mostly just so they could leave addressing
black widow the other dead characters in future
movies like we already saw iron man's funeral
during avengers end game but they're going to
address black widow's character during the black
widow movie the writers and the producers also
clarified that throughout the series throughout
all the episodes there were a lot of intentional
red herrings that were meant to go nowhere like a
really good example biggest red herring is dotty's
character like early in the episodes i think it
was episode two where agatha harkness says dottie
is the key to everything in town so there were all
these theories about her being one of these other
big comic book characters that was another witch
hiding out in town another magic user when really
none of that was going on at all and the writer
said that was on purpose they purposely wanted
to mislead you and make you think that she was a
big character when really she was not so i think
that also goes hand in hand with the ralph bohner
evan peters quicksilver twist like they wanted to
sort of head fake you in a way that would make
you think something really big was going on
when really that wasn't their intention which
i don't think was such a great idea but i think
the answer to that like if you were kind of upset
with the way it treated some of those story lines
falcon and winter soldier will be more of a
straight up mcu action series where they're not
trying to mislead you or take you down roads that
never wind up going anywhere so falcon and winter
soldier will be a really good palette cleanser
before we get to more marvel stuff later this year
like the black widow movie or the hawkeye series
not every single marvel series will work like
Wandavision did but what's gong to happen is my
falcon winter soldier episode 1 video we'll post
next friday it'll be on the same schedule as when
i posted all my Wandavision episodes if you have
any big questions or there any easter eggs that
you're not sure about that i didn't mention during
this video or big deleted scenes that i didn't
address just let me know in the comments but
really cool thing benedict cumberbatch has been
saying all kinds of really awesome stuff about
sam raimi elizabeth olsen as well so it sounds
like that movie is going to be crazy in the best
possible way benedict cumberbatch also refused to
answer questions about spider-man 3 no way home
so it sounds like that is also going to be super
crazy but while you wait for everything click here
for that brand new falcon winter soldier trailer
and click here for all my Wandavision episodes
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!